le ciel de cette ville de l'ouest de la
crim est recouvert d'un épais nuage noir
plusieurs explosions viennent tout juste
de se produire elles ont eu lieu tout
près d'un aérodrome militaire russe dans
un dépôt de munitions des explosions qui
ont fait au moins un mort et plusieurs
blessés si tu as la situation est sous
contrôle seuls les habitants des maisons
situées dans les alentours de la base
militaire vont devoir s'installer
ailleurs les maisons sont examinées pour
vérifier les dommages qu'il ya eu
la crimée péninsule ukrainienne annexé
par la russie en 2014 est aujourd'hui
une base de premier plan pour moscou
dans la guerre en ukraine les autorités
russes affirment cependant que le dépôt
n'a pas été visée par un tir où un
bombardement
dans son allocution quotidienne
volodymyr élise qui n'a pas hésité à
évoquer les explosions et le statut de
la péninsule se renier baratin
aujourd'hui il ya une attention toute
particulière à la crimée et c'est normal
au cra la crimée ukrainienne il n'y
renoncerons pas nous n'oublierons jamais
que l'occupation de la crimée a été le
début de la guerre russes
aussi savina proto de nombreux touristes
russes passer leurs vacances dans cette
station balnéaire de crime et plusieurs
évacuations ont dû être organisées à la
suite de ces explosions